hello and welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2018 my name is Oscar
Deus and I'm joined by creative director
of FIFA 19 Matt prior Matt how you doing
I'm doing I'm great to be here has the
show been through so far it's been great
it's been great getting feedback always
this bringing it to consumers we've just
done EA play and had a lot of people
playing the game and/or getting all the
good feedback on that so yeah it's
always great to bring bring our hard
work to the masses awesome yeah and we
finally saw the reveal of FIFA 19 on
stage a press conference but not a lot
was really said on stage so tell us more
about what we can expect what's new this
year and P 419 yeah so there's lots new
and we'll be rolling out more
information as we kind of head up to
launch but for now here at e3 in EA play
the main thing is obviously Champions
League so the champions these licenses
back in FIFA it's been gone a few years
and we're very proud to bring it back
because obviously a FIFA we pride
ourselves on authenticity and the lack
of the Champions League was obviously
something that was missing and it is and
always has been one of the most
requested two features from our
community so it's always great to be
able to give the community what they
want so yeah so we're very proud to
bring that back and when we did bring it
back we wanted to bring it back in such
a way that it affected all users
irrespective of what mode they play
because the thing one of the interesting
thing with FIFA is there's very
different users within the game because
there's just so much in the game so you
have the foot user career mode user
journey user so when we brought the
Champions League back we wanted to bring
it throughout the mode so we have a
standalone mode where you can just dive
in and play the Champions League and
that can be the authentic version or if
you are a user who whose team does not
make the Champions League so maybe
Bristol City you can actually put
Bristol City in the Champions League and
live that dream and I'm a Man City fan
for many years we never got close now we
do thankfully so that's the standalone
Champions League mode we also have it in
career mode so now career mode is the
fully authentic experience and is the
most authentic it's been in many years
and it's not just the Champions League
that comes with the UEFA license we also
get the Europa League and the Super Cup
so career mode has all those licenses we
also have the journey so it's the final
year of the Alex hunter story the end of
the trilogy and part of the narrative
arc of that will be him chasing the
ultimate in club football and that's the
Champions League glory and then we also
have it in foot so we will file for
items live live events based on the real
world Champions League because one of
the beauties of thought is that
connection with the real world you know
what happens in the real world is
reflected in foot so we'll be able to do
more of that more of that through
Champions League and then the other
piece of the Champions League is not
just kind of bringing the license but
doing it justice the the UEFA guys have
created an amazing brand with the
Champions League and if you've been
looking after been to a Champions League
game the atmosphere is very different
they create a unique atmosphere so for
us it was hugely important to create
that so we obviously got the iconic
anthem or the trappings or the regalia
that goes with a Champions League match
the night lighting but also we've got a
brand new commentary team which really
kind of differentiates it from a regular
game so not only do you get the visual
difference you also get the audio
difference so we're delighted to
announce Derek ray and Lee Dixon will be
the Champions League commentators so as
a complete package we've kind of covered
everything so yeah we're very proud to
be bringing the Champions League back to
FIFA awesome yeah and that really adds
to FIFA's of the cosmetic side of it
which FIFA does so well and has them for
many years but but what can people who
have played hundreds of hours fee for a
team what's what's changed on the pitch
yeah so I mean that's the other part and
the important thing obviously the big
announcement here is that the Champions
League license but fundamental to FIFA
always has been always will be his
gameplay that I added already at its
core what is most important in FIFA so
again we'll be rolling out more
information around gameplay but the
features we're looking at here there's a
there's a few of them so we've got
advanced touch system which is a whole
new system of the user touching the
board trapping the ball striking the
ball and as you can imagine that's a
pretty common thing in football so a
radical reroute of that system has
implications throughout the game and
then from the user perspective of what
that actually means to them it means
more authenticity a lot more variety of
animations in the way they trap and
touch the ball a lot more fluidity and
perhaps most importantly a lot more
responsiveness so though you'll you'll
feel that system you'll feel the change
in that the responsiveness and a couple
of additional features we've been able
to implement because of this reroute of
that system is missed misguided trapping
so you can now receive the ball look to
trap one way and go the other way so
it's kind of a bit of a mind game with
your opponent and it works on the AI as
well and the other one is an all new
flick system so as you receive the ball
you can now use the
it's like a stick to flick it in various
different directions so that and also
flick it up to score like the Wonder
Girls the volleys so that's another
level of control which really kind of
opens up the game and adds a new
dimension we've also got dynamic tactics
so this is a complete rewrite of a
tactic system so now not only will be
there more they'd be more obvious so
when you change your tactic you will
visually see that on screen they're also
a much more customizable now so you can
literally dive it in and customize your
tactics to suit your style of play the
team you use I'm a man City fan and
we've got Pacey winger so an hour I can
customize my tactics to really make use
of them so there's now a level of depth
to tactics like never before so if you
have if you're always you know losing to
two teams because they're coming through
the middle or down the wings you can now
have a lot more ammunition in your
arsenal to kind of combat that so a lot
more and to make your experience very
unique to you and there are also quick
triggers in the game so you no longer
have to pause the game and go into it so
a lot on the tactics side we've also got
a feature called time finishing so this
is an optional shooting mechanic so you
can shoot in FIFA as you always have
done but now we have an additional
mechanic whereby if you press the shot a
second time and you time it right you
will get additional power accuracy and
curve so very much a risk/reward
mechanic cause the alternative if you
don't hit it correctly is you know you
shank it into rosette kind of thing so
the visual cue to time it correctly is
that players fought to hit in the ball
so if you time it as the animation
triggers you will get that accurate
accuracy and it's not an always goal by
any stretch of the imagination all it is
is that additional level of power and
accuracy if you get it right so for me
personally I only tend to use it when
I'm having a bit of a hit and hope you
know it's a bit speculative you know
gareth bale's second goal in the
Champions League final would have been a
good example of where you might want to
use that obviously you can't guarantee
carry asses in goal but well that kind
of thing right you wouldn't want to use
it five yards out with an empty net so
it so it is that a little element of
risk reward and a little bit more
control for those users that want to use
it and then we've also got a real player
motion technology which is a system we'd
introduced in 18 which is a more fluid
player
unique system that gives an authenticity
it's the system we use to create running
style so Renaldo runs Lateran although
sterling runs like sterling you know
that kind of thing so we've now applied
that to a lot of other systems in the
game so you get that player personality
throughout the game not just in the
running running motion so that's another
big one and the final one we're
discussing here is 50/50 battles and
that's a rewrite of situations which
happened throughout the game when
there's a ball that's free two players
are going in for it there's now a whole
new system that determines what happens
there so again from a user perspective
what you will see is much more realistic
physical collisions much more realistic
and organic ball physics as a result cuz
it's non-deterministic and or in any way
it's determined with the players mass
the players angle his attributes and
then the what happens to the ball is the
real-time physics system so again the
user feels much more organic and free
free football so a lot of systems across
the board more to follow but it's
another another big big year for for
gameplay yeah definitely it sounds like
that and we'll those those improvements
specifically to the the tactics side of
it and the shooting does that apply to
the AI as well am I going to I want to
be able to notice the difference between
playing say Man City or Barcelona and
playing against Stoke City absolutely
sorry to all the stoke fans out there
yeah absolutely yeah that's another key
thing we've given more tools to the user
to customize their team to that how they
play the same is true of our data guys
who kind of showcase how other teams
play so we will apply real-world tactics
so you know you get the press in from
one city etc etc so again adds the level
of authenticity not just to the to the
user and their kind of freedom of how
they want to play but also to the
real-world teams and how they will play
so perfect example you did right there
playing Stoke will feel very different
to play Man City and and I'm personally
more of an offline person but I know
there are a lot of Ultimate Team fans
out there as well is there anything more
you can tell us about Ultimate Team or
the journey or career mode as well
because again that's just my personal
preference yeah no all very great modes
and and unfortunately not talking too
much about them here we want to save
some ammunition for the rollout towards
towards
launch so yeah so the journey we can
dive over to this final
chapter in Alex hunters story there will
be a lot more to tell you about that as
we roll out a lot more surprises I think
where we take the story everyone will be
kind of surprised and delighted it's a
very interesting narrative that we've
done and interesting options within that
thought as I say more will be divulge
with photos we roll out we've got the
Champions League which obviously brings
a lot of excitement and again a lot of
more opportunities kind of connected to
the real world and then career mode is
another one we will have further
announcements but obviously one of the
big ones for that is the inclusion of
the Champions League and how authentic
that makes that mode awesome well I'm
really looking forward to hearing more
about it
I'm afraid that's all we've got time for
today guys but for everything else on
FIFA 19 and for everything else from e3
2018 stay tuned the game spoke on
[Music]